- Breakups suck, but they're
not the end of the world.
There are going to be plenty
of more fish in the sea,
so don't trip over one small one.
(upbeat music)
- That everything was gonna be okay.
You're allowed to do well on the test,
but you're also allowed to fail sometimes,
and you just keep going.
- To not be afraid to be yourself,
because back in the day, I was very shy,
and I was very reserved.
I didn't get to do a lot of things
that I wished I got to do,
just because of my shyness.
- The problems you think you're having
are like not a big deal,
like most of these problems are gonna
work themselves out with age.
- In high school, I was
always scared of doing
the wrong thing or getting in trouble,
but now I know that it's not that deep,
so go do something you're scared of.
- You should not be afraid,
as cheesy as it sounds,
to chase a dream.
That anything is possible.
You really should just
like follow your heart,
move away, explore the world,
do whatever you want, and
don't feel like you're stuck
wherever you are.
- In high school, I used
to get made fun of a lot
for making YouTube videos,
so back then I wish that
I knew to just not get
discouraged by that.
- I wish I knew that you
could take a gap year
between high school in college.
- College is really expensive,
so missing out on some
parties and actually
doing good on your SATs is a good idea.
- Also, save your money.
If you have some type of
income in high school,
at least save five bucks in a bank account
so you have money to your name
when you get into college,
and then in adulthood.
Also, it's just like a good practice
to have under your belt.
- I'm gonna switch it up a little bit.
There are some things I
wish I knew in high school
that I still don't know,
like how to change a tire,
or how to do taxes, or just be an adult.
(upbeat music)